yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing on you watch only runs for five
marine okay so I'm gonna Moscow
variation of them Sicilian six okay it's
a bit uncommon to play like this she go
97 you usually play cookie 6 B 5 but
yeah I'm going to try to open the center
yeah that whole combination of moves the
rule is a little bit a little bit
strange as it weakens so many squares
like d65 and so on hmm I don't really
have a direct way to use it
yeah I'm good did this prevent a 6 B 5
you know II cannot I cannot know I was
really thinking he could play a 65 no
but it's not possible I'm on that too a
little bit too often yeah the night III
move
I wanted to again cover b5 and maybe
later night c4 III d5 can be played okay
I'm going all the way back down I'd see
form forgetting night C 0.85 it would be
really nice but he would go b6 almost
for sure oh okay again that's an odd
move how to see hmm
yeah me yeah but that doesn't work why
does that work
I mean after if I take and I go here how
do you cover it 97 okay I have a 5 that
also looks excellent this is probably
even stronger
I mean he's playing very been a very
backward way he like 97 and back hmm
yeah it should be pretty pretty nice for
me okay
night see form1 yeah there's nothing
really wrong about taking this first
let's try to win a fight right away I
don't see how he really saves it
hmm I don't want to allow him to to give
me the double pawn I already don't it's
not a problem per se
let's just take a five I mean moving
that night to d2 means I cannot take a
fighter and I mean yeah that was the
only thing that worried me a little bit
but that cannot be the end of the world
I always have before before now one Nazi
form
Nazi force maybe maybe the best simply
sending him back yeah while sending it
back the rook yeah that looks like a
decent technical move roopd agency only
move otherwise is in a fork okay yeah
sending your rematch over that is one of
the problems see a little bit the
problem is a bit strong but if you want
to do brief analysis it's a bit
unfriendly not to respond to the rematch
often but I want to do a brief brief
look at the game
yeah I already disliked you six and
because I mean black is not really
fighting for the center with this move
it's the problem it makes perfect tense
pretty much regardless of what pawn
formation you want to play for to play
this first and detect this so that I
have to play as no one move like Queen
e2 is what I'm going to play him which
is of course not bad for white but it's
still a slight concession you move the
Queen and it's not so active to play
Queen e2 and
and g6 gives me more conveniently
castles and rook e1 which is that useful
all of the time and yeah now e5 is
weakening us enter quite a bit again
there's nothing decisive but it adds up
Queen d6 given by the engine yeah
briefly thought about that but no yeah
it's more powerful yeah you cannot
really deny that and it simply threatens
the spawned so the engine he gives
castles side against that if I kept
salutely have no better idea I can win
that porn which funny enough the engine
doesn't even like it gives black almost
adequate compensation yeah in this
position minutes possible I mean that
actually possible it feels a little bit
audien that there should be almost
enough compensation as I have no one no
serious weakness and he still has two
bad pieces it's quite remarkable
of course Bishop is six and he's better
developed but I would still be pretty
optimistic in this position that I'm
just in the long run we'll be able to
convert that pawn my computer is not a
bishop a6 roopd alien it's connected
pieces they're still yeah hmm it's still
remarkable I would think that white
should be able to consolidate and get to
a position where you convert this okay
but I went a form castles 93 this keeps
a convenient satiric advantage funny
it finds a master game the opening is
pleura from this position yeah 98 the
the main thing with this is that it also
weakens c5 I mean I was expecting Queen
to c7 I was thinking here 94 b6 this is
almost the only move if I get a 5 and
that that's going to be too terrible
fixing all the pawns and so on so b6 and
then I thought Queen D 6 M yeah it's a
bad position
d 6 week d5 Big B 6 week he's got tons
of weaknesses yam 98 and yeah this is
just falling apart of the a5 let's see 4
is also strong ok and it's it's a very
convenient choices him
yeah and just night c4 ascending the
rook back black should go to d8 of
course but it is very bad Knight b6
before moves like that I would probably
play before a6 is not going away and I'm
on that Bishop and rook and you're not
going to hold that note that all blacks
pieces are basically ineffective the
night only 7 and so on that it really
looks very ineffective this is something
that I mean like Here I am
you really don't want to go to e7 just
the knight on f6 at least attack
something and on e7 that looks at
protected squares I mean you can go
there if you really have a an idea how
to reroute it but it's not going to be
good only 7 ever yeah thanks a lot for
watching